let's go next to uh why don't we try
mitch from toronto canada mitch you are
on the air
hey david can you hear me i can hear you
fine yeah
okay great um long time listener i
actually just uh became a member the
other day great uh love your program
thank you i appreciate that
for sure um so i don't know if you
follow anything going on in canada but
what i wanted to ask you about was more
i guess cross-border anyway and it has
to do with the environment and kind of
like where things are going in the
future in terms gas prices are getting
crazy up here uh in canada at least in
ontario they're getting crazy and i
think they're getting pretty expensive
in in the us as well
um
what are your thoughts on like moving
people to electric cars subsidizing that
um and if you have any thoughts on like
how that how that's playing in with with
home ownership condo or otherwise i
would love to hear your thoughts on that
kind of scenario let me i'll get back to
the second part yes i mean listen gas
prices are going up they are not at
historic highs but they are higher
um i am a huge advocate of electric cars
i've had one now for over a year i think
that
there's an incredible double standard
where you have the very same people
complaining about high gas prices and
blaming them on biden want to prevent
biden from doing more on building an
electric vehicle charging network and
subsidizing electric vehicles
incentivizing electric vehicles etc etc
we have some subsidies at the state and
some at the federal level for electric
cars it's not nearly enough so if you
want to
solve the gas price problem let's get
off of gas that's number one
number two
in terms of the home ownership and condo
thing
i listened to a very interesting podcast
recently which basically says the path
forward is we need government to
subsidize
retrofitting you go building by building
structure by structure
and you put solar panels on the roof or
in the yard depending on whether it's
urban rural
you replace and retrofit heating systems
to be modern ultra efficient often they
are heat pump mini split systems
although there are many other ways that
there's not just one system but you know
we got to get off of burning oil for
heating
certainly baseboard electric is like one
of the least efficient it's a disaster
you replace stoves with ultra efficient
new electric and i love gas as much as
the next person but in this way
you create each building takes in solar
power has the most efficient electric
elements for cooking and heating and
you've got a car charger so you're
charging the car with the sun
this is the process you've just got to
start doing it you've got to you've got
to start going building by building
government's got to figure out how to do
it we got to get off this gasoline stuff
we just have to yeah
yeah yeah yeah what is that podcast i'm
curious where you're getting some of
your information i wish i remembered
what it was i i just don't um no problem
no let me see if you let me give me give
me one second let me see if it's still
in my spotify history i'm just looking
at it on my underwear well you're
looking i'm also curious what kind of
electric car you've been driving i've
been driving a tesla
okay you've been driving to tesla now
are you driving the uh like the van
sedan i think that's the model x or are
you on the the model s
well i don't want to say specifically
because the vehicle is kind of
conspicuous you know yeah um
i don't um
you know i it might have been it might
have been brain stuff but i don't know
i don't know what the podcast was but in
any case is it in the winter how do you
find it in the winter well the thing
with electric vehicles is when you use
the battery
to run the heat pump to heat the car
it does consume significantly more
battery so the range is notably
decreased in the winter it's never been
a problem particularly with the
supercharging network and a high-speed
charger at home it's never caused a
problem for me
but there's trips where in the summer i
might finish the trip at 40 percent
where i'm rolling in at 22 in winter if
i'm running the heat at 70 or something
like that
that's good to know hey thanks so much
for taking my call i really appreciate
it and um i would love to hear
uh
more of your thoughts on this kind of
stuff on your program at any point if
you decide to cover it um i'm really
interested in in some of the more
granular stuff around this and would
love to hear more of your thoughts all
right i very much appreciate the call
thanks so much david all right take care
uh guys pretty solid calls today so far
let's not ruin it please please nobody
ruin it um why don't we go
next
to brett from i believe it's indiana is
that right brett
correct can you hear me i can hear you
fine
all right perfect hold on a second i
gotta go somewhere discreet sorry uh-oh
discretion is key with many of these
calls
right i'm at school so i don't want to
offend anybody but anyway so two
questions and i'll be quick so please so
so for me as a national guard member do
you think it would be cheaper
if the usa spent more on the national
guard as compared to active duty i don't
know just i don't know if you're
informed on that or not i just was
curious as to your thoughts on that i
don't know enough about that to comment
substantively to be honest
or i understand i mean it's just
if we spent more domestically it
certainly
mathematically could save more because
you know we wouldn't have to spend money
sending them to another country and we
would could focus on domestic issues you
know because there are like military
jobs where like they do something as
simple as work on railroad trucks or you
know
you know washers and dryers you know
there's even combat medics but
that's just my view it's an interesting
question i will look into it
i appreciate it so
do you know so here's my last question
do you know if there's
with the infrastructure bill that biden
just signed yep
um
there's a possibility of magnetic trains
being included into it or because i
tried to look into that and i didn't see
anything about it so i know that there's
a there's a designation of money
specifically for rail and there's also a
designation for
um uh public transit and both of those
things can touch train travel i don't
know let me put it this way i haven't
seen anything about maglev trains
specifically but that doesn't mean it is
in there or it isn't in there i just
haven't seen it at that level of
granularity
right because when i was in paris i went
from paris to madrid on a magnetic train
i was very impressed by the speed i was
like wow holy crap i i like you did you
say madrid
yeah metro does paris
are you talking about madrid spain
yeah i like that i've never heard it
pronounced madrid but i sort of like it
well it depends on what language i'm
speaking so if i'm speaking spanish i'll
say like madrid but if i'm speaking it
to like you know an english speaker i'll
say it as madrid hey listen right if
it's work no i love it if it's working
for you keep going i like it
alrighty i appreciate your time all
right thanks brett there's brett from
indianapolis dropping in a variety of
different opinions questions comments
etc
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle
on the blinkist app i just listened to
this is your mind on plants by the great
michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2.
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below